This morning,
the nominees were announced
for the 89th Academy Awards.
And in contrast
with last year's slate
that provoked the
Oscars So White hashtag,
this year features a diverse set
of nominees,
including a record
six black actors.
Then again... then again,
a record-tying 14 nominations
also went to La La Land,
which is pretty much the whitest
(bleep) movie imaginable.
-(laughter)
-I haven't seen it.
I don't know.
It just doesn't seem like
a movie I'm gonna see, but...
From what I hear--
I'm just piecing this together--
but I think
it's about Ryan Gosling
explaining jazz to Emma Stone,
and I assume
includes such songs as,
"I Brought My Own Cloth Bag
to Whole Foods,"
and "Extra Mild Salsa, Please."
The only thing whiter
than La La Land
would be a biopic about
the invention of mayonnaise,
-which...
-(laughter)
...incidentally
is in the works, you guys.
Daniel Day-Lewis is gonna be
amazing in this movie.
-Amazing.
-(laughter)
He pretended to be mayonnaise
for, like, six months
to get ready for this. Like...
So, comedians, what's an even
whiter musical than La La Land?
-Kate.
-The Grand Wizard of Oz.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
-That'd be very white.
-(applause and cheering)
-Very white. John.
-Annie Get your UGGs.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Claudia.
-How to Succeed
in Everything
Without Really Trying.
-(laughter, applause)
-HARDWICK: Points. Points.